Bienvenidos a reporteros soy herminia
Fernández en los últimos 10 años los
ciclistas colombianos han brillado en
las distintas competiciones mundiales de
ciclismo sin embargo existe un lado
oscuro que empaña la reputación de
Colombia en este deporte el dopaje esta
nación tiene el mayor número de
ciclistas sancionados por dopaje junto a
Costa Rica e Italia me encuentro con
tres periodistas deportivos de este
canal Juan pupiales Rodrigo sedano y
Lionel puzzerie han realizado
investigación exhaustiva que muestra
Cómo funciona el dopaje en Colombia que
hace el país para evitarlo y cuáles son
las consecuencias para los deportistas y
el ciclismo colombiano un placer
tenerlos hoy aquí cuéntenos un poco más
esa historia que veremos en breve
con una desconocida en el mundo del
deporte como una potencia al nivel
mundial en el ciclismo les doy un dato
que refleja esto desde el año 2000
solamente cuatro países han ganado el
Tour de Francia el giro de Italia y la
vuelta a España son Reino Unido España
Italia y Colombia Sí pero pese a este
dato que indica a mi compañero Lionel
puig seguí colombias también uno de los
países que más sancionados tiene la
lista de la unión ciclista internacional
un total de siete y de hecho la propia
federación colombiana de ciclismo cuenta
ahora mismo con 32 sancionados por este
flagelo de hecho es una preocupación
latente dentro de los propios ciclistas
de las propias estrellas del ciclismo
colombiano aquí hemos hablado con egan
Bernal campeón del Tour de Francia de
2019 o en el Felipe Martínez ellos
mismos nos han expresado aquí su
preocupación no solamente por el dopaje
en el en Colombia sino también a nivel
latinoamericano
Gracias compañeros en breve volvemos con
ustedes aquí la historia
[Música]
Colombia el ciclismo es orgullo nacional
sus corredores son considerados como
estrellas héroes en todo el país son los
campeonatos nacionales de ruta y la
multitud vibra con el paso de pelotón
pero en una nación que desde el 2016 ha
ganado las tres grandes vueltas dopaje
se muestra como La Cara Oculta de la
moneda entre el público una persona
espera muy atenta la llegada del ganador
Tirso zorro trabaja para el Ministerio
del deporte y es quien supervisa en el
campeonato a este grupo de voluntarios
de la organización nacional antidopaje
la unad
tenemos a los chaperones
por lo general que están identificados
con control dopaje tienen unas planillas
ya identificados los deportistas que se
van a hacer digamos la toma de control
que están dispuestos listos para
notificar al deportista una vez
notificado del deportista el chaperón se
queda totalmente con él la labor de los
chaperones es clave particularmente este
año ya que el campeón de la categoría
élite de la edición anterior resultó
positivo por dopaje pocos días después
de su Victoria
a la fecha de publicación de este
reportaje en la lista vigente de
sancionados y de suspensiones
provisionales de la federación
colombiana de ciclismo muestra 32
nombres una parte de esa lucha contra el
doping comienza aquí en los controles en
competencia el chaverón está esperando
expectante porque pues los medios de
comunicación
abordan a los ciclistas pero él no le
puede perder la mirada al ciclismo
dentro de sus funciones el chaperón debe
asegurarse que el deportista no orine ni
entre al baño hasta el momento del
control se busca evitar que se contamine
o adultere la muestra pues esta es la
estación donde se hace toda la toma de
la de la muestra y Pues digamos una vez
obtenida la muestra termina ya el
procedimiento para que el atleta pueda
salir Por razones jurídicas el
Ministerio del deporte no autorizó a
grabar el momento de la muestra Pero
estos controles no son los más
eficientes a la hora de detectar
irregularidades
en este edificio de Bogotá se encuentran
la organización nacional antidopaje que
depende del gobierno central Orlando
Reyes está la cabeza de la institución y
explica la importancia de los controles
fuera de competencia
actualmente en Colombia nosotros estamos
haciendo aproximadamente un 60% de la
muestras fuera de competencia y un 40%
de muestras en Competencia por qué se
hace eso porque las personas que de
pronto no están de acuerdo con los
comportamientos éticos en el deporte de
ellos hacen digamos unos tratamientos
con o pueden hacer unos tratamientos con
sustancias prohibidas antes de las
competencias de tal manera que ya en la
competencia llegan y prácticamente las
sustancias pueden ser indetectables en
2021 la organización nacional antidopaje
colombiana realizó un total de
2.248 controles para todos los deportes
de ellos 1621 tuvieron lugar fuera de
competencia para perseguir a los
deshonestos
cuenta con 30 médicos distribuidos en
todo el país mucha suerte
Mario Acosta es uno de ellos su misión
de hoy realizar un examen de orina en la
casa de un ciclista
estos controles se hacen sin previo
aviso al deportista y según Mario son
pocos los que presentan resistencia
son muy contados esos esas ocasiones en
que ellos se incomodan la mayoría son
deportistas muy abiertos a colaborar
podemos hacernos un poquito más adelante
por favor
Mario aún no sabe si el deportista se
encuentra en su domicilio
Hola Mucho gusto Mario Acosta cómo está
Ministerio del deporte tengo un control
antidopaje sí que hay que hacer es una
muestra de orina Entonces
si me permites para poder seguir y poder
hacer el proceso
sí Ah bueno Muchas gracias no se permite
estar presentes durante la toma de orina
45 minutos más tarde Mario ha acabado el
control
las pruebas ahora emprenden un largo
viaje al extranjero
laboratorio de Bogotá a uno se ha
acreditado por la agencia mundial
antidopaje y están en el proceso de
acreditación en 2017 el laboratorio
colombiano perdió la acreditación de la
agencia mundial antidopaje por incumplir
los estándares Internacionales es por
eso que todos los muestreos del país se
envían a laboratorios que sí están
certificados entre ellos el de solt Lake
City en Estados Unidos o el de Montreal
en Canadá
una situación que dificulta el cuidado
de las pruebas y aumenta el costo de los
controles fue precisamente en un control
fuera de competencia que dio positivo
este ciclista no verán su cara ni se
publicará su nombre solo aceptó dar su
testimonio bajo anonimato por seguridad
se ha alterado su voz y se han omitido
detalles de su declaración en su
testimonio señaló que fue su director
deportivo quien lo convenció de doparse
antes de una competición profesional en
Colombia
digamos
[Música]
por médicos por ciclistas que ya no han
usado pues uno uno ha escuchado eso no
Uno ha escuchado que sabe uno deportista
sabe que el pueblo más perseguido acá en
Colombia en el mundo
yo en principio dije No No porque yo
sabía que eso es complicado eso siempre
es intramuscular intravenoso esa
sustancia no Entonces no es que yo no sé
por qué salí o no algo que me echaron
Entonces yo yo esperé pensé
epo tres letras para eritropoyetina esta
hormona favorece la producción de
glóbulos rojos y aumenta el suministro
de oxígeno los músculos con ellos se
busca mejorar la resistencia
a tomar esa decisión a último momento de
eso de que tenía que llevar comida a mi
casa de que tenía que vestir a mi
familia
pasaron unos días y llegó un control
antidopaje nuestro ciclista da positivo
asustado contactó a su director
Claro
pero el mal que dice bañarse las manos
usted sabe quién soy yo y si nos
queremos ir por las malas nos vamos por
las malas usted tiene familia desde una
que digan eso a uno Eso ya es amenazan y
que hace uno pues ya penagro porque
es muy reconocido
en América Latina y acá en Colombia es
muy muy muy reconocido de la mano del
resultado positivo llegó una sanción de
varios años sin poder competir es
entonces que su cabeza empieza a dar las
vueltas que ya no dan las ruedas de su
bicicleta los pensamientos de retirada
del ciclismo dan paso a episodios de
depresión
[Música]
llorando no dormía no comía porque creo
que estaba en mi mejor momento de mi
carrera deportiva está
brillando Donde había mucho sacrificio
para llegar donde estaba y que por un
error por por creerle a unas personas
de que nadie va a pasar se me derrumbó
todo
cuando hablamos de sustancias dopantes
en Colombia conseguirlas es bastante
fácil o eso nos dice Joan roballo un
conocedor del mundo del ciclismo
colombiano
Se presenta como fabricante de ropa
deportiva es también el único sancionado
en Colombia por su ministro e intento de
suministro de sustancias dopantes a
ciclista
que nunca le ha contado Sí tuve una
sanción por administración o incurrir a
un ciclista ciclomontanista yo es hoy
entrenador de ciclismo y en algún
momento le está haciendo la
planificación a un ciclista de la Master
en el caso por el cual está sancionado
él niega a ver administrado la sustancia
tras 24 contractó al corredor quien
mantuvo su acusación contra robayo pero
no quiso dar su versión delante de la
cámara en el momento de que tuvimos la
audiencia en la federación
No aparecían ninguno no tenía el más
ninguna evidencia la cual a mí me
ubicará como que yo le vendía él el
medicamento y que con ese medicamento él
salió positivo simplemente que en algún
momento yo hablé de rabia en ese momento
que estamos y el abogado lo que hizo fue
anotar Y yo le dije al Man Ey Por qué me
haces esto si sabes que lo único que yo
te dije por teléfono cómo colocarte esa
inyección sin embargo aceptó la sanción
porque reconoce que en un momento se
lucraba del dopaje no me lavo las manos
ni me quito la culpabilidad yo en algún
momento lo hacía tú me preguntabas a mí
por algo y yo yo te conseguía cualquier
eso porque pues yo era un comerciante
Entonces
como es un negocio muy natural y digamos
que me da tristeza pero así es
en España en Francia en Italia en
cualquier parte del mundo Argentina
chile en esas partes del mundo donde no
hay ningún control antidoping el mercado
es bravo después de ser sancionado Joan
lanzó su marca de ropa de ciclismo que
además patrocina un equipo femenino a
nivel nacional Esta es la camiseta de
campeón de la vuelta a Colombia ella es
Miriam Núñez nosotros ganamos y tuvimos
la fortuna de ganar la vuelta a Colombia
con ella en el 2020 nos asegura que la
venta de sustancias dopantes hace parte
de su pasado y que el problema del
dopaje va más allá de su caso personal
es una pelea es más más eso que no tiene
fin Tampoco porque lo que les digo a mí
me quitaron del camino que en algún
momento lo hacía y detrás de mí venían
20 personas más y después de esas 20
personas más seguirán como el ciclo del
narcotráfico quitan a un campo y vienen
días más detrás el dopaje en Colombia
afecta a gente que tiene la bandera del
juego limpio como Consigna de vida el
doctor Luis saldariaga es uno de los
técnicos más reconocidos del país
dentro de los talentosos ciclistas que
entrenó hay figuras como nairo Quintana
Y Sergio higuita ha sido un luchador
contra el doping y así lo manifestó con
su trabajo en el equipo manzana Postobón
que llegó a disputar la vuelta a España
en 2017 y contaba con un programa
antidopaje propio nuestra batería mejor
que el de la UCI incluso que la UCI
tiene también un pasaporte biológico
nosotros teníamos pasaporte biológico
pagado a la UCI pasaporte biológico
interno de nuestro equipo pero bueno eso
es es la línea de esto cuando estás por
el bien algunos que están por el mal a
pesar de este programa dos casos
positivos provocaron la desaparición de
su equipo después del retiro del
principal patrocinador una falta de
conocimiento hay gente que cree que que
si va al gimnasio dos tres veces a ganar
fuerza sale el otro y le dice no eso
viene una pastilla Entonces es como
pasar saltarse todas las líneas directas
éticas que hay en la vida
Y eso nos está afectando hay gente que
quiere Resultados ya quedó claro
de enero a septiembre de 2022 7
ciclistas colombianos han sido
sancionados por dopaje un castigo que no
supone necesariamente el fin de una
carrera deportiva con esa redención a un
sueño a nuestro testigo protegido
bien otros días que no que digo que no
no no no no no no quiero volver pero ya
llegó a la casa del otro día tengo ganas
de volver mi objetivo es Volver volver a
dejarla la imagen que dejé en mi última
carrera de que los técnicos me dirán
valió la esperanza tenía objetivo es
Volver
al llegar al nivel que que llegue a
estar en ese tiempo
[Música]
muy interesante la historia qué otra
información consiguieron durante la
investigación y que no vimos en este
reportaje
hay una información importante que es
que varias fuentes que no aparecen en el
reportaje que han visto ahora es que
estas personas nos hablaron de casos de
corrupción que pueden ir hasta rebajas
de sanción en caso de control positivo
en contra de suma de dinero bastante
importante sin embargo estas personas no
quisieron estar registrada en cámara
Durante este reportaje esta
investigación Sí pero pese a ello pese a
lo que cuenta mi compañero Lionel a
nosotros Nos gustaría seguir
investigando sobre estas preguntas
actuaciones por eso les invitamos a que
si tienen algún tipo de denuncia al
respecto o sobre dopaje en general tanto
en Colombia como en el resto de América
Latina nos lo hagan saber si Rodri por
eso para la audiencia ofrecemos el
siguiente de correo Franz 24 e
s@porton.m24es@porton punto mm es un
dominio que les garantiza una seguridad
que les garantiza una privacidad extrema
a esa información que ustedes pueden
compartir con nosotros para continuar
con esta investigación gracias compañero
por este reportaje y gracias a la
audiencia por sintonizarnos hasta la
próxima